y ahora
[Música]
yo soy de las que cree que la educación
es la ruta para construir un mundo mejor
para tener una sociedad más justa para
que aquellos que nacieron en la pobreza
tengan mejores oportunidades ya eso
dedicado toda mi carrera pero descubrí
hace poco que el vehículo para
transitarlas ya no es la escuela al
menos no como la conocemos ahora y eso
lo descubrí cuando tuve un hijo
cuando él era pequeño lo que más así era
preguntar
qué es esto por qué pasa esto para qué
sirve
con cada pregunta con cada respuesta con
cada descubrimiento una chispa se
encendía en sus ojitos y yo alucinaba
que algo así estaba sucediendo en su
cabeza fuegos artificiales todo
conectado ideas encendidas
él creció sus primeros tres años en el
parque
pero un mes antes de que cumpla 3
yo que si me muero me fumo le fallaron
los dos al mismo tiempo llegué con las
justas de la emergencia y me
hospitalizaron los doctores que ven mis
placas de ese momento no entienden cómo
sobrevivir esos son unos pulmones sanos
y acostado mis pulmones de ese momento
tapados no tenía aire
sentado al pie de mi cama mi hijo que
tomo la mano y me dijo no te preocupes
mamita yo estoy aquí
y viéndolo ahí yo supe en ese momento
que tenía que vivir no podía dejarlo
solo su papá falleció antes de que el
nazca
lo que hicimos toda la vida pero fue su
cáncer el que nos impulsó a tomar las
decisiones importantes decidimos
casarnos formar una familia tener un
hijo aprovechar el tiempo que nos quede
juntos es curioso lo clara que se ven
las cosas cuando el fin está cerca
salí de la clínica y un mes después mi
hijo comenzó su nido era un colegio que
yo había escogido para él muy
cuidadosamente
pero pasaban las semanas y él no se
acostumbraba cada día lloraba más y se
resistía a ir y yo me sentía horrible no
sabía si dejarlo faltar o se obligarlo a
ir a pesar de su llanto las profesores
me decían no te preocupes ya se va a
adaptar
déjalo nos reunimos varias veces para
tratar de entender qué pasaba cómo
podíamos ayudarlo hasta que un día me
asomé por la puerta de su salón y lo vi
trabajando en su sitio
esa imagen me golpeó muy profundamente
su chispa se había apagado
y en ese momento yo me cuestioné qué va
a pasar con su luz con esa ilusión de
aprender luego de 14 años de lo mismo me
di cuenta de que mi hijo no se estaba
adaptando se estaba resignado
yo quería que su chispa se vuelva un
fuego que sus ganas de aprender no
mueran no quería que mi hijo se resigne
había asumido como todos en mi alrededor
que el colegio de ese lugar donde tienen
que estar los niños porque si no a donde
irían
conversando con varios amigos todos me
decían amigos si le gusta su colegio a
mi hija le encanta el colegio pero
cuando les preguntaba qué es lo que más
le gusta de su col de cualquier encara
la respuesta
exacto el recreo los amigos para eso
mejor que se quede jugando en el parque
pero no todos juegan la vida me decía
una terca voz interior cómo se va a
preparar para el futuro
mi hermano me había existido durante
hacía ya tiempo que de qué educamos a
nuestros hijos en casa home schooling
pero yo no veía de dónde sacaría el
tiempo ni la paciencia para hacer algo
así hasta que un día me dijo una palabra
que lo cambió todo para mí
micro escuela entonces google y
descubrir que efectivamente mi hijo no
tenía que resignarse a una rutina
escolar es más esa rutina no les iba a
servir para el mundo que le toca vivir
es decir lo tortura hoy y no lo prepara
para el futuro eso me fascinó desvelada
por la cortisona que tomaba para curar
mis pulmones leía día y noche quería
entender cuál es la mejor educación que
existe hoy en el mundo cuál es la forma
natural en la que aprenden los niños qué
tipo de persona con qué habilidades con
qué conocimientos
va a poder vivir plenamente en el mundo
cambiante de hoy tuve que cuestionar
todo lo que yo creía y sabía
la escuela como la conocemos ahora
existe hace menos de 150 años pero en
todo ese tiempo su formato no ha
cambiado mucho
aulas estudiantes carpetas profesores
clases timbres y hoy entiendo
que lo que diseñamos en el siglo 20 fue
un buen bus ese bus es la escuela tiene
al frente un chófer un adulto que
conduce un grupo de niños al mismo ritmo
por la misma ruta hacia un objetivo
definido por el sistema el vehículo el
modelo educativo tenía mucho sentido en
ese momento el gran desafío del siglo 20
para el perú y para muchos países era
que todos nuestros ciudadanos tengan
educación
y llevarlos a todos conducirlos por la
ruta de la educación en los primeros 50
años del siglo 20 se duplicó el todo el
conocimiento humano pero luego tardó 20
años más para volverse a duplicar y
luego 10 y a partir de los 80 con la era
de la información ese ritmo de creación
y renovación de conocimiento se aceleró
y este siglo el crecimiento se ha vuelto
exponencial si el año pasado se duplicó
el conocimiento en 12 meses se calcula
que el próximo año se va a duplicar cada
12 horas todo el conocimiento mundial
qué significa esto para la educación
para la escuela para nuestros hijos
para empezar significa que no tiene
sentido es inútil trazar una sola ruta
para que todos las sigan de la misma
manera es más las grandes empresas de
tecnología ya no buscan el diploma
universitario sino gente que sepa
programar con elegancia sobreponerse al
fracaso aún si no ha estudiado nada
formalmente lo que importa es lo que
saben hacer no el diploma lo que importa
es su carácter demostrado en la cancha
no las recomendaciones de sus profesores
el vehículo ya no es el bus la escuela
sino el niño mismo sus manos sus piernas
sus ojos su mente todo su ser
dejemos que los niños avancen a su
propio ritmo lo que los niños necesitan
ahora no son choferes que nos conduzcan
sino guías que los orienten en este
mundo cambiante que los inspiren y los
aliente a emprender su propio viaje ya
no por una carretera bien demarcadas
sino por un campo abierto
sorteando obstáculos por sí mismos guías
que sean capaces de darles los mapas de
ruta el equipamiento necesario para
encontrar su camino las pautas para
avanzar bien guía que sepan leer el gps
de cada estudiante para saber dónde
están si están perdidos o si necesitan
ayudas guías que sean exploradores
también que no tengan miedo a
aventurarse hacia lo desconocido
a reconocer que no saben aprender algo
nuevo cada día esos son los verdaderos
maestros del siglo 21 lo que necesitamos
es dejar a los niños aprender a moverse
en un mundo en constante cambio sin
perderse
por todo eso sé que a mi hijo del
colegio difunde un espacio nuevo tipo y
marca significa en quechua punto de
encuentro o también encuentro de pueblos
en tipo y marca no hay profesores que
enseñan hay guías que acompañan equipan
inspiran empoderan
no hay salones ni tampoco grados hay
espacios donde niños de diferentes
edades aprenden juntos
no hay clases ni exámenes hay trabajo
autónomo
y evidencias de aprendizaje no hay
libros de texto estáticos
igoogle con una mente crítica y el
conocimiento que cree se cambia cada día
5 y marca academy no es un colegio
alternativo es una alternativa al
colegio
estamos afiliados a una red
internacional de micro escuelas llamada
acton academy
somos ya más de 150 en todo el mundo y
creciendo a gran velocidad lo que nos
une
es que creemos que todo niño es un héroe
que merece encontrar un propósito en la
vida que cambia el mundo ese llamado que
lo moviliza a vivir una gran historia
esa es la brújula que debe guiar su
propia educación su ruta única
el propósito es la intersección entre
los talentos que desarrollamos con
esfuerzo y mucha muchísima práctica
las cosas que disfrutamos plenamente y
nos hacen perder la relación del tiempo
y aquellas oportunidades injusticias que
vemos en el mundo y que nos tocan en el
alma
la corrupción la guerra el hambre la
pobreza la injusticia la discriminación
utilizar nuestros talentos para
construir un mundo mejor
todos tenemos esa responsabilidad y los
niños las niñas también pueden cambiar
el mundo si los dejamos porque no se
trata de educar individuos que sean
exitosos pero que sólo se miren a sí
mismos porque al final todo ser humano
busca un sentido a la vida que
trascienda su propia mortalidad porque
lo que queda
en este mundo que transitamos son la
huella que dejamos en el mundo y en
aquellos que caminaron a nuestro lado o
que cruzaron por nuestro camino
por eso antiguo y marca academy cada
héroe avanza a su ritmo matemáticas
lectura escritura inglés temas de
interés personal se vuelven lectores y
escritores apasionados porque lee y
escribe lo que les apasiona aprenden a
buscar información a analizar y
seleccionar
aprenden a fijarse metas y monitorear su
avance si esas metas aprenden a
organizar su tiempo a controlar su
distracción encontrar su ritmo y se
distraen se equivocan se atrasan se
frustran vuelven a intentar todo con
autonomía
y aprenden jugando con aventuras
apasionantes en las que van conquistando
retos con el uso de la ciencia la
tecnología las artes las matemáticas y
la ingeniería convertirse en
emprendedores y vender sus productos en
una feria perseverando a través de
varios fiascos
convertirse en jardineros
y aprender de biología y de botánica
y el valor de los hábitos al sembrar su
propio huerto
convertirse fabricantes de juguetes y
aprender las leyes de la física a través
del diseño en la ingeniería del ensayo y
del error
convertirse en detectives y aprender de
anatomía a través de la ciencia forense
con el reto de analizar una escena del
crimen y descubrir al culpable
en 5 marc academy no hay pasajeros hay
héroes en ruta cada uno responsable de
su propio aprendizaje a más esfuerzo
gana más libertad más posibilidades de
decidir sobre su tiempo y sus
actividades si no se esfuerzan pierden
libertad y privilegios no hay notas hay
consecuencias
nadie les quita la libertad ellos solos
la pierden por lo tanto ellos pueden
volver a recuperarla así es como se ve
cuando tú eres tu propio vehículo nadie
te lleva tú avanzas tú misma te frena si
te caes te levantas no es una ruta fácil
pero es
más genuina y respetuosa con la
naturaleza de los niños conecta mejor
con el mundo real y forja un carácter
noble y fuerte yo fundé tingo y marca
para devolverle la alegría y la emoción
al aprendizaje y a mi hijo la
responsabilidad de emprender su propia
ruta
es la mejor decisión que tomaría en tu
vida le dijo jorge a una amiga que
visitaba a cinco y para postular
el año pasado fue nuestro primer año y
terminamos con 12 estudiantes y este año
abrimos con 42 pero nuevamente
mi salud fallo al inicio de este año los
doctores me dijeron que tenía una
enfermedad degenerativa que no tiene
cura y que acabaría con mi vida
lentamente en unos 10-15 años quién sabe
ya se imaginarán el susto
pero también debo confesar un poquito de
alivio y es que a mí siempre me han
asustado las metas de largo plazo y
ahora tenía que enfocarme en vivir bien
10 años de mi vida no toda una vida solo
10 no tenía que planear mi vejez
pude ver cómo serían esos 10 años
y me sentí muy agradecida
pude ver el tiempo que me queda para
hacer las cosas que me falta hacer y vi
que era suficiente
inmediatamente todo lo que no valía la
pena lo que era un desperdicio en mi
tiempo se hizo evidente y mis
prioridades las vi muy claras aprovechar
cada minuto que pueda con mi hijo crear
un proyecto educativo viable
para él y para otros
y no postergar más los viajes que
siempre quise hacer
así que tome licencia de trabajo para
enfocarme mi salud y mi hijo y poco a
poco empezamos a viajar juntos después
decidí renunciar
y seis meses después nuevos doctores me
dijeron
el diagnóstico está equivocado que si me
iba a curar
yo les digo el susto
y la deuda
valieron la pena
se los recomiendo piensen bien qué
historia quieren vivir que valga la pena
ahora y que ocurra en los próximos diez
años
hoy tengo y crece yo veo a mi hijo feliz
su chispa está viva mis prioridades
están claras
así que cuando un niño te diga no me
gusta ir al colegio yo quiero que sepas
que tiene razón él también merece vivir
una gran historia ahora no en 15 años
escúchalo
[Aplausos]